.
Kein Traumhaus - ein Traumturm:
der denkmalgeschützte Wasserturm
in Cuxhaven an der Nordsee.
Ihn zu renovieren und auszubauen -
das ist die Vision.
Es wäre witzig,
hier ein Café einzubauen.
Es ist schon ein schweres
Millionenprojekt, das ist so.
Was sich Familie Caboussat aus dem
Emmental nicht hat träumen lassen:
Also, nehmen wir den raus.
Nico, du kannst
auf der anderen Seite ziehen.
... wie viel Mühe,
Nerven, Jahre und Geld
sie dieses Projekt kosten wird.
Fenster: 203'000 Euro.
Nein, hör auf!
Wir müssen vorwärtsmachen.
Es geht auch um die Baugenehmigung.
Der Turm
verlangt den Auswanderern alles ab.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Gut, gehen wir mal rauf.
Mal schauen.
Du, ich habe das Gefühl,
hier riecht es nach Pisse.
Ja, es riecht nach Pisse.
- Ins Rohr, oder wer weiss wo.
Hier hat wieder einer hingespuckt.
Ich muss sagen,
die sollen aufhören,
mir auf den Boden zu spucken,
verdammt noch mal.
Das ist widerlich.
- Das ist zum Scheissen.
Hier sollte nicht zu sein.
- Es ist Mai 2023.
Eine Flut
von kleinen und grossen Problemen
zerrt an Alain
und Mirabelle Caboussats Nerven.
Hier riecht es auch so.
Aha, ich weiss warum.
Weil die Kanalisation
offen ist, natürlich.
Hinten in der Ecke.
- Ja, aber ...
Nicht aber, das ist so.
Hat nicht jemand runtergepisst?
Nein, das ist die Kanalisation.
Sie haben nicht zugetan.
Man muss einen Zapfen drauftun.
Ja, natürlich.
Das hätte der Sanitär machen sollen.
Der stillgelegte Wasserturm.
Sechs Jahre nach dem Kauf ist er
immer noch eine grosse Baustelle.
Die Eröffnung zögert sich
eins ums andere Mal hinaus.
Ich versuche,
die Kugel dort oben zu machen.
Die Besitzer
packen wenn immer möglich selbst an.
Darunter kommt Gold hervor.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Bis ins Detail
behalten sie alles im Auge.
Wer weiss.
Unbeirrbar.
Ehrlich gesagt,
gab es schon Momente,
in denen wir den Anschiss hatten und
uns fragten: "Was machen wir hier?"
Aber wir mussten
schon so viel beissen,
halten und durchhalten,
dass es schade und blöd wäre,
wenn wir sagen würden,
wir hätten genug.
Nein, nein, jetzt sind wir
viel stärker und positiver.
Irgendwann
kannst du dich nicht mehr ärgern.
Also, ich kann mich schon noch.
Ja, du kannst dich
schon noch manchmal ärgern.
Fünf Jahre zuvor:
In Langnau im Emmental
packen die Caboussats ihre Sachen.
Ihr Einfamilienhaus
haben sie verkauft.
Ein voller Lastwagen,
das ist die ganze Habe,
die sie mit ins neue Leben nehmen.
Ja.
Schatz,
wir müssen wirklich vorwärtsmachen.
Die wollen gehen.
- Ich weiss.
Koffer nicht mitnehmen.
Sohn Yannis soll in Cuxhaven
die obligatorische Schulzeit beenden.
Sein älterer Bruder Nicolas
wird eine Lehrstelle suchen.
Ich konnte mich darauf einstellen.
Das weiss ich ja schon länger.
Darum bin ich nicht wirklich: "Ah!"
Los geht's!
Fast 1'000 km nordwärts ...
... ans Wattenmeer.
Hier in Cuxhaven haben Caboussats
für den Anfang eine Wohnung gemietet.
Vier Zimmer.
Es wird enger als in der Heimat.
Das hier ist eine Übergangslösung.
Von den Räumlichkeiten her
ist es gut.
Wir müssen weniger putzen,
wenn wir rausgehen.
Das ist ein Vorteil.
Die Stadt Cuxhaven
ist ein Tourismusmagnet.
8 Mio. Tagesgäste
kommen jedes Jahr in die Region.
Der Wasserturm,
der 2004 stillgelegt wurde,
soll bald als neue Attraktion
wieder erstrahlen.
Aber zuerst muss die Familie
in den Alltag finden.
Du musst aufstehen.
Willst du eine Ovo?
Der erste Schultag.
Ich hoffe jetzt wirklich
das Beste für sie.
Dass sie gute Freunde finden,
gute Lehrer,
und sie sich
richtig integrieren können.
Das ist das A und O im Moment.
Was ich ganz sicher mitnehmen würde,
ist ein Heft,
ein Etui,
damit du Sachen notieren kannst,
die du brauchst.
Ja, ja.
Wo muss ich schon wieder hin?
- Um die Ecke.
Also, dann gehen wir mal rauf.
Mal schauen.
Und die Eltern?
Ihre neue Aufgabe
ist der 46 m hohe Wasserturm.
Lokaltermin
mit dem Architektenteam aus Hamburg.
Wir haben schon ein bisschen
mehr Klarheit wegen den Fenstern.
Caboussats haben grosse Pläne.
Hier soll ein Gewerbe reinkommen.
Eine Boutique, eine Weinhandlung.
Einfach etwas Spezielles.
Dann gäbe es
auf den nächsten Etagen B&B.
Je zwei Zimmer.
Im dritten Stock
wäre eine Ferienwohnung.
Oben gäbe es ein Café.
Und vielleicht,
wenn es geht, eine Wohnung.
Eine Wohnung für die ganze Familie -
das ist der Traum.
Die Machbarkeit des Umbaus
haben Alain und Mirabelle Caboussat
vor dem Kauf geprüft.
Sie gehen gut vorbereitet
in das Abenteuer.
Das ist der Wassertank.
Der ist ... Wie hoch?
12 m?
- 12 m.
Von hier aus.
Der Tank,
gross wie ein Einfamilienhaus -
hier, hoch oben im Turm,
soll das Café entstehen.
Wir haben ein gewisses Budget,
das wir gesetzt haben.
Wir müssen schauen,
was Sinn für die Zukunft macht.
Ganz grob, ohne,
dass wir uns festlegen müssen:
Dieses Jahr wird geplant, nächstes
Jahr beginnen wir mit dem Bau.
Wie lange man braucht,
müssen wir schauen.
Ein Jahr Bauzeit brauchen wir schon.
Wir haben schon mal
ein Haus umgebaut.
Wir wissen, dass nicht alles
nach Plan läuft. Das ist so.
Mirabelle soll recht behalten.
Schon bald ist die gelernte
Buchbinderin mitten im Baustress.
Per Mail ist ein Angebot
für den Einbau eines Lifts gekommen.
Es sind Leute gekommen,
die geschaut haben,
wie es machbar ist.
Die haben verschiedene
Brandschutzsachen gehabt,
die wieder Fragen aufgeworfen haben.
Es ist manchmal recht aufwendig,
bis man zum Ziel kommt.
Alain ist derweil zurück in Bern.
Bis der Gästebetrieb im Turm läuft,
zählt die Familie
auf seinen Verdienst
aus dem früheren Job.
C'est tout en ordre?
- Oui, ça va bien.
Haben Sie gesehen?
Dort war noch Dreck.
Als Messeleiter
behält er alles im Blick.
Es geht immer um sehr viel Geld
bei einer Messe, um viele Leute.
Das müssen wir perfekt machen.
Nach diesem Mandat
will Alain Caboussat
als Freelancer im Messebau
Geld verdienen, so der Plan.
Machen wir auf?
In 2 Min? Oder in 30 Sek.
Das Projekt Wasserturm steckt
immer noch in der Bewilligungsphase.
Also. Gut.
Ein Jahr
ist seit der Ankunft vergangen.
Wegen des Cafés oben im Wassertank
sind noch immer viele Fragen offen.
Der Turm ist zu hoch -
zu hoch für die Leiter der Feuerwehr.
Wir warten seit vier Monaten
auf den Bericht vom Brandschutz,
wie es genau geht,
denn das Gebäude
ist sehr komplex für den Brandschutz
und wir wollen nur ein Treppenhaus
behalten. Das ist unser Ding.
Jetzt mussten sie Vorräume
und Schutzräume machen,
und einen Überdruck im Treppenhaus,
damit keine Rauchentwicklung
passieren kann.
Deswegen geht es nicht vorwärts.
Das Entkernen übernehmen sie selbst.
Alles, was gemacht ist,
ist ein Schritt vorwärts.
Und alles, was wir selbst machen,
müssen wir nicht bezahlen.
Aber die Verzögerung zermürbt.
Wir müssen vorwärtsmachen,
auch wegen der Baugenehmigung.
Die müssen wir einreichen.
Nichts geht mehr - auch bei Alain.
Wegen der Coronakrise
wurde eine geplante Messe abgesagt.
Ja, das Problem ist einfach,
dass das finanziell
gar nicht mehr möglich ist.
Eben, aber Kunststofffenster
sind ca. 60'000 Euro günstiger.
203'000 Euro.
Hör auf, nein.
Das müssen wir runterbringen.
Monate gehen ins Land.
Grosse Brombeeren.
- Das gibt dann Konfitüre.
Monate mit neuen Auflagen
und neuen Anforderungen.
Das, was hier z.T. demoliert ist,
oder so aussieht,
ist ein Materialprobengutachten,
das wir machen mussten.
Das gibt Analysen.
Das kostet Tausende von Euros.
Wir mussten auch klären,
ob im Zweiten Weltkrieg
Bomben runterkamen
und in der Nähe sind.
Das ist nicht der Fall.
Aber das kostet alles.
Caboussats suchen Hilfe ...
Hallo. Guten Morgen.
(Mann) Herzlich willkommen.
Hier noch was Kleines
für die Kaffeepause,
damit Sie noch etwas
von der Schweiz haben.
... beim neugewählten
Oberbürgermeister von Cuxhaven.
Wir sind ganz froh,
dass Sie da sind
und dass Sie mit Ihrer Initiative
diesen Wasserturm
noch mal zum Leben erwecken.
Holzfenster kosten über 65'000 Euro
mehr als Kunststofffenster.
Beim Dach muss man schauen.
Das Geländer innen.
Aber wir können uns das
einfach nicht alles leisten.
Das können wir nachvollziehen. Da
gab es ja auch einen ersten Impuls,
auch von der Wirtschaftsförderung.
Das gehen wir nochmals an.
Bei den Fenstern wird es bleiben,
aber wir können schauen,
dass wir es mit dem einen
oder anderen Fördertopf hinkriegen,
dass Ihre Belastung zumutbar ist.
Ja, wir brauchen die Unterstützung.
Ohne geht es nicht. Das ist so.
Die Hoffnung auf Subventionen
zerschlägt sich bald.
Wir haben
keine Fördermittel bekommen, nichts.
Leider hätten sie kein Geld
in den Töpfen, angeblich.
Das hat uns der Denkmalschutz-
beauftragte auch wieder gesagt.
Und dann sagt man, man freue sich,
dass wir das Projekt machen.
Das verstehen wir nicht
unter Unterstützung.
* Kirchenglocke *
* Ruhige Musik *
Das Hauptprojekt steht still.
Es braucht neue Geschäftsideen.
Caboussats
eröffnen ein rollendes Café,
mit dem sie Märkte besuchen.
Hast du die Milch
für denCappuccino schon gemacht?
Ich bin dran.
Den alten Citroën
haben sie eigens umbauen lassen.
Der Kaffee ist gefragt.
Heute sind sie
für einen Firmenanlass gebucht.
Es ist schön,
wennes so super läuft.
Aber Alain war auch schon am Hafen
und ei, ei, ei ...
Wenn das Wetter schlecht ist,
stehst du nur.
Aber es ist ja gut.
Es stimmt für uns in diesem Rahmen.
Aber wir sind schon froh,
wenn wir endlich eröffnen können.
Sie haben mit dem Wasserturm zu tun?
- Genau.
Wir hoffen,
nächstes Jahr zu eröffnen.
Das muss sein. Sonst ist der
Spassfaktor irgendwann mal zu Ende.
Das ist untertrieben.
Geldsorgen treiben Caboussats um.
Bis nachher, Schatz.
- Ja, tschüss!
Jeder Euro ist willkommen.
Wir wollen so gut als möglich
von den Einnahmen leben.
Das Ersparte
ist für den Wasserturm gedacht.
Hallo.
- Hello.
Der jüngere der beiden Söhne,
Yannis, ist im letzten Schuljahr
und möchte eine Ausbildung
zum Forstwart beginnen.
Du hast Gemüse, Yannis.
Merci vielmals, Schatz.
Nicolas beendet bald
seine Ausbildung zum Hotelfachmann.
Ich möchte in die Schweiz zurück
und mal das Militär machen.
Damit ich das gemacht habe.
Dann schaue ich weiter.
Ich denke, wir dürfen nicht
etwas aufbauen und sagen,
die Kinder übernehmen es dann.
Das ist der falsche Weg.
Jeder soll sein Ding machen.
Vielleicht kommen sie zurück
und finden es cool.
Oder sonst ist es unser Ding
und wir müssen weiterschauen.
Das kann gut sein.
Über drei Jahre lang
versuchen die Caboussats alles,
um ihren ursprünglichen Plan
umzusetzen.
Vergeblich.
Der grosse Traum zerschlägt sich.
Schliesslich treffen sie
einen tiefgreifenden Entscheid.
Hast du den Baubeschrieb gefunden?
- Ja.
Sie werden ihr Projekt
radikal verkleinern:
Es wird kein Café im Wassertank
geben,
hoch über der Stadt.
Die Brandschutzauflagen,
die Hochhausrichtlinien
wurden so enorm und aufwendig,
dass wir fanden,
wir müssen
eine andere Lösung finden.
Das bedeutet, dass wir nun
das Café hier unten haben.
Und dann geht es hier
ins erste Obergeschoss,
da wäre die erste Ferienwohnung.
Im zweiten Obergeschoss
ist die zweite
und die dritte
ist unterhalb des Technikbereiches.
Vom Tisch ist auch der Traum
von der eigenen Wohnung im Turm.
Schon bald werden sie das re-
dimensionierte Baugesuch einreichen.
Es wird im Sommer 2021 gutgeheissen.
Endlich kann es losgehen:
Die Bauarbeiten beginnen aussen.
Hier oben ist die schönste Aussicht.
Es gibt nichts Schöneres.
* Möwenkreischen *
Zwei Jahre später.
Gut, gehen wir mal rauf.
Die Treppenstufe
muss ich noch reparieren.
Wir können es provisorisch machen.
- Ja.
Ich probiere es mal, Schatz.
Noch immer ist der Turm
eine Baustelle.
Handwerker zu bekommen -
eine Glückssache.
Schatz, wie ist es?
Ja, es kommt nicht durch.
- Schau mal, ob sie hält.
Ja.
Doch, die hält. Das ist gut.
Da haben sie auch schon
alles gespachtelt.
Da ist alles fertig gespachtelt.
- Tipptopp.
Jetzt kommt die Kante hier.
Im Inneren sind die Arbeiten
langsam in Gang gekommen.
Jetzt müssen wir die Türen ...
Ich will das Glas rausnehmen.
Für das Schlafzimmer?
- Ja.
63,5 cm.
Das kannst du aufschreiben: "Glas".
Hier muss "Glas" stehen.
"Erdgeschoss".
- Habe ich: "EG".
Jetzt kommt "1. OG, Schlafzimmer".
Hier haben sie geputzt.
Die Heizkörper
haben sie hierhin getan.
Die sind aus der Schweiz
und die sind rund, extra für hier.
Gebogen.
- Die kommen hierhin.
Und das Schönste am Ganzen:
Es stimmt, was ich gemessen habe.
Darauf bin ich sehr stolz.
Das macht natürlich Freude.
Jetzt sieht man es optisch.
Das sah man lange, lange nicht.
Es ist wirklich so.
Man muss zuerst abbauen.
Dann kann man richtig aufbauen.
Jetzt müssen wir das Rohr
unbedingt noch anstreichen lassen.
Die Problematik bei diesem Rohr ist,
dass es unglaublich teuer ist.
7'500 Euro um 36 m anzustreichen.
Es braucht Brandschutz-Spezialfarbe,
mehrere Schichten.
Wenn ich sehe, was wir
für Brandschutzanlagen haben,
die Detektion für kleinste Sachen -
eine Riesensache
und wahnsinnig teuer.
Trotzdem müssen wir das
immer noch machen.
Dafür haben wir
nicht so viel Verständnis.
In den Ferienwohnungen
tut sich etwas.
Wir haben gerade Ihr Werk bestaunt.
Es sieht supergut aus. Hallo.
Sind Sie zufrieden?
-Wir sind zufrieden.
Sehr zufrieden.
Es passt zu den Wänden,
zu den Steinen an der Wand.
Wirklich. Es passt wirklich gut.
Ich glaube,
die sind heute Abend fertig, Schatz.
Der Wasserturm scheint auf gutem Weg.
Ein günstiger Moment
für einen Abstecher in die Schweiz.
Sohn Yannis hat seine Pläne geändert:
Nicht Forstwart,
Bäcker-Konditor will er lernen.
Und zwar hier im Zürcher Unterland.
Ist Herr Baumgartner da?
Ich rufe ihn an. Kleiner Moment.
Guten Morgen. Hallo, Yannis.
- Grüezi, Herr Baumgartner.
Grüezi. Caboussat.
- Alain Caboussat.
Freut mich.
Wir tragen keinen Schmuck -
Ohrringe ausgenommen -,
und tragen Haarnetze.
In der Bäckerei Fleischli hat der
20-Jährige bereits geschnuppert -
beide Seiten waren zufrieden.
Nehmen wir mal den ersten Schritt.
Das wären die Arbeitspläne.
Das wäre z.B. der TPFR,
Tortenposten früh, 2 Uhr Start.
Schlafe 6, 7, 8 Std.,
damit du mitziehen magst.
Das ist der Tipp,
den ich dir mitgeben kann.
Du kommst gerade von oben.
Ja, genau.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob das aus eurem Umfeld kommt.
Er wusste: "Ich muss etwas machen,
ich muss anpacken."
Er stand nicht nur einfach da.
Das freut uns extrem.
Das tut uns sehr gut als Eltern,
dass wir das so übermitteln konnten.
Es gibt genug Menschen,
die zu kurze Arme haben
und die Arbeit nicht erreichen.
Das wollten wir nicht
für unsere Jungs.
Ich mache das für die Nachwelt.
Das ist gut.
Es heisst Abschied nehmen.
Das machen wir nicht jeden Tag.
- Nein.
Und ich trage selten ein Netz.
Ginge es nach Mirabelle und Alain,
wäre der Wasserturm
schon längst fertig umgebaut.
Stattdessen ist jetzt eine Art Vor-
eröffnung im Aussenbereich geplant.
Heute kommt es darauf an,
wie gut wir vorbereiten.
Es kommen mir immer wieder
Sachen in den Sinn.
Es ist viel.
Jetzt muss ich noch mal
rasch schauen, ob er da ist.
* Vibrationsalarm *
Er hat ein Händchen.
Das passiert uns öfters.
In 10 Min. bin ich da.
- Tipptopp.
Sehr gut. Das passiert öfters,
dass wir etwas sagen wollen,
und genau ... Es passt einfach.
Neben dem Druck und der Belastung
gibt es so viele Entscheidungen.
Wir müssen schon gleich ticken.
Sonst hätten wir eine Riesen...
Es ginge schlichtweg nicht.
Aber es funktioniert zum Glück
immer noch.
Hallo, Schatz.
Bald wollen sie
erstmals Gäste empfangen.
Noch bleibt ein Tag
für die Vorbereitung.
Ich bin sehr gespannt,
wie das morgen wird.
Wenn das Wetter gut ist, ist gut.
- Ja.
Entweder werden wir überrannt
oder ...
... wir sind ganz allein.
- ... wir haben ein paar Nasen.
Oder wir haben einen schönen Tag.
Ich schaue auf diese Seite.
- Ja, ist gut.
* Ächzen *
Geht's?
Sonst helfe ich dir schnell.
Seit ihr alter Citroën
den Dienst versagt hat,
sind die beiden mit einem
neuen Kaffeemobil unterwegs.
Aber auch dieses Gefährt ist
mittlerweile nicht mehr fahrtüchtig.
Ich bin die meistabgeschleppte Frau
von ganz Cuxhaven.
Es ist ein Samstag im Mai 2023.
Am Sonntag ist der Blumenmarkt.
Und wir wurden
vom Eventmanager angefragt,
ob wir gerne dabei wären,
und wir sagten Ja.
Wir dachten, wir könnten
schon aufmachen, innen auch.
Damit war nichts.
Jetzt sind wir draussen
und weihen die Terrasse ein.
Wir haben nur noch Kosten.
Jetzt müssen wir irgendwie
eine Lösung finden,
um die Saison mitzunehmen.
Ich gehe davon aus,
dass wir Ende Juni
innen mit allem so weit sein werden.
Wenn wir nicht noch mehr
verarscht werden, geht das.
Es ist viel passiert.
Und zum Teil auch nicht.
Wir bekamen mit den Handwerkern
ein Riesenproblem.
Aber auch mit den Materialien,
die nicht mehr kamen.
Das hat sich alles verzögert,
durch die Pandemie
und jetzt noch durch den Krieg.
Das gab Verzögerungen allgemein.
Das Schlimme ist, dass
die Handwerker viel versprochen,
aber nicht gehalten haben.
Im Wasserturm
steckt das ganze private Vermögen,
auch der Erlös aus dem Verkauf
des Einfamilienhauses in der Schweiz,
dazu ein Bankkredit
und private Darlehen -
und doch wird es knapp.
Die Finanzierung
ist wahnsinnig schwierig geworden,
weil alles raufgegangen ist -
auch bei der Sparkasse.
Es ist so teuer geworden
mit den Zinsen.
Wir können nicht neues Geld nehmen.
Und weil alles raufgeht,
das Holz und alles,
haben wir immer mehr Ausgaben.
Das ist das Verrückte. Und die Löhne
gehen rauf. Alles geht rauf.
Darum machen wir das
mit den Steinen.
Die Leute können auch noch spenden.
Wir können sie noch setzen.
Aber es ist ein kleiner Tropfen
auf den heissen Stein.
Ah, hallo, Entschuldigung!
Wissen Sie, wann das hier öffnet?
- Nein. Das steht in den Sternen.
Morgen ist hier aussen geöffnet
und innen vielleicht ab Juni.
Wie spät ist es?
12.18 Uhr.
Ich wollte noch mit dem Strom
hantieren, aber das geht nicht.
Wir hätten das vorher machen müssen.
Du hattest keine Zeit.
Wir können uns nicht spalten.
Ich nehme diesen Filter gleich mit.
Caboussats sind erschöpft.
Seit Jahren
ist der Druck konstant hoch.
Hallo. So.
Streuobst, Litschi, Kräuter,
Holunder, Ingwer, Zitrone.
Sehr gut.
Ich bin im Schilf.
Vielleicht sind es 150,
vielleicht nur 60.
220.55 Euro. Guten Start.
Wird schon schiefgehen.
Schönen Tag! Danke, tschüss.
Ranunkel, Freesie, Calla,
Gerbera, etwas Beiwerk.
Eukalyptus, Schleierkraut.
Das ist ganz nett,
das macht es zarter.
Ja, das ist doch gut.
Ganz Cuxhaven ist gespannt,
dass endlich eröffnet wird.
Das ist doch gut.
Hat ja auch lange gedauert.
- Ja, ja.
Es ist erst aussen,
innen ist nicht fertig.
Ich komme am Sonntag mal schauen.
- Wunderbar, sehr schön.
Die Leute
warten schon gespannt darauf.
Viele werden enttäuscht sein,
weil es nur draussen ist.
Aber es ist ein Start und es wird
sich zeigen, wie das ankommt.
Ich muss voran, nicht?
Ich weiss nicht, ob wir
hinten beim Rad vorbeiwollen.
Eins, zwei, drei!
Die Kaffeemaschine
kommt frisch aus dem Service zurück.
Schauen, ob das geht.
Nein, es funktioniert nicht.
- Das Problem ist ...
Jetzt ist sie ja schon warm.
Und der Dampf kommt raus.
Es baut keinen Dampf auf.
Deshalb beginnt der Boiler
verrückt zu spielen.
Dampf, Dampf, Dampf,
und er kommt nicht.
Und der Hebel ist zu.
- Der Dampf sollte ...
Es geht auch wahnsinnig schwer.
Ich kenne die Technik da drin nicht.
Für 650 Euro finde ich ...
Das Problem ist einfach, dass morgen
der Event ist. Jetzt ist Mittag.
Mirabelle sucht Rat beim Hersteller,
schriftlich.
Schau mal selber.
Was soll ich jetzt damit?
Wir können die
nicht selbst auseinandernehmen.
Aber da zahlst du weniger.
(Mann) Ja?
- Ja, hallo, morgen.
Wir haben ein kleines Problem.
Vielleicht kannst du uns helfen.
Ich drehe mal die Kamera.
Dann spricht mein Mann dazu.
Entschuldigung.
- Hallo. So. Sehr gut. Also.
Was ihr jetzt machen könntet ...
Den Griff kann man abschrauben.
Ja. Gut.
Dann kann man den rausnehmen.
So. Und das geht drinnen
auf den Stössel drauf.
Ich habe nicht
das richtige Werkzeug.
Wir haben die Revision bezahlt,
wir können hier
nicht noch mal den Service machen.
Nein, es geht nicht.
Wir haben noch so viel zu tun
bis morgen.
Uns läuft die Zeit davon.
- Es geht nicht.
Es bewegt sich zwar,
aber es funktioniert gar nicht.
Was ist die Lösung jetzt?
Die Lösung wäre gewesen,
den Stössel zu flicken.
Ja, aber der geht ja nicht.
Das würde ich doch gerne machen.
Ich habe jetzt abgestellt,
sonst kommt nur noch Dampf.
Da stimmt etwas nicht.
Jetzt ist sie runtergefallen.
Scheisse.
Es muss jemand kommen. Fertig.
Ich habe Wochenende,
das ist das Problem.
Aber da muss eine Lösung her.
Wirklich.
Ja, gut, warten wir.
Caboussats können nur hoffen,
dass sich der Techniker
auf den Weg macht.
Um 16.30 Uhr schliesslich
trifft er ein.
Sehr gesprächig
ist er allerdings nicht.
Daumen drücken.
Ah, jetzt aber.
Innen ist ...
Wie hast du das genannt?
Stössel.
Der Stössel
war ganz krumm, ganz gebogen.
Ganz gebogen.
Wie auch immer das passiert ist.
Dann geht es schnell.
Gut, nicht?
- Ja, da bin ich glücklich.
Es dampft genau,
wie es dampfen soll.
Ah!
Tschüss, danke.
Der grosse Tag der Ausseneröffnung.
Eine Freundin hilft.
Hallo.
- Wie geht es dir?
Noch eineinhalb Stunden
bis zum Start.
Eigentlich
sollte ich ganz ruhig sein.
Aber wenn man alles
perfekt machen will
und weiss:
Es ist noch nicht perfekt ...
Nur nicht viel sagen.
Sonst gibt es noch mehr Stress.
Das bringt gar nichts.
Probier mal, Schatz.
- Ah, schön, merci.
Ein Doppelter!
- Du brauchst das.
* Mirabelle lacht. *
Kommt gut, Schatz, kommt gut.
- (Mann) Mirabelle!
Es geht hier gleich los.
Um 11 Uhr.
Ich drehe durch.
- Mach dich auf etwas gefasst.
Was hilft mir der?
Ich will noch einen reinhauen.
Schatz,
ich muss das Auto wegstellen.
Das geht nicht mehr.
Und du musst
den Filterkaffee machen.
Ja, der Tisch ist frei,
ich mache es.
Dann kannst du
das vorne hübsch machen.
Schatz?
- Da ist noch ein Teil ...
Es ist nur der Espresso drin.
- Und der Guji?
Der ist noch nicht drin.
Wann hätte ich das machen sollen?
Schon gut, schon gut.
Kein Problem.
Das geht grad so.
- Nein, nein.
Wo hat er mein Verlängerungskabel?
Scheisse.
Wo hat er es hingetan?
Hat er es ins Auto gelegt? Scheibe.
Morgen.
Kann man Kaffee haben?
- Nein, es ist noch nicht so weit.
Ich hasse es so -
den Zeitdruck und das Provisorische.
Das macht mich ganz konfus.
Schatz, es tut mir leid,
dass ich nicht weiter bin.
Schatz, wir müssen aufmachen.
- Ich weiss.
Ich weiss, dass du es weisst.
Aber jetzt muss man handeln.
Um Punkt 11 Uhr geht es los.
Was hätten Sie gerne?
- Einen Espresso.
Espresso.
Oder ich habe auch Filterkaffee.
Wie Sie wollen.
Dann nehme ich den Filter.
- Einen Filterkaffee, gerne.
Du, Schatz, du musst mir schon
sagen, was die Bestellungen sind.
Einen Espresso, habe ich ja gesagt.
Muss ich schreien?
Ja.
Bald steht fest:
Das Café vor dem Wasserturm
ist eine willkommene Attraktion
an diesem Markttag.
(Frau) Ganz, ganz toll. Wunderbar.
Wir sind zu wenig Leute.
Wir hatten es noch gedacht,
aber es ist schwierig,
jemanden zu organisieren.
Etwas Schokoladenpulver?
Du, ich muss schnell
wegen der Tassen schauen.
Warte, ich gehe rasch.
- Gehst du? Soll ich übernehmen?
(Frau) Zwei Cappuccino.
- Zwei Cappuccino, gerne.
Für mich ist es chaotisch.
Ich habe praktisch
nicht mehr geschlafen.
Mehr kannst du nicht machen.
Sie haben sich
noch nicht hinten angestellt.
Doch, ich habe mich angestellt.
Ich dachte, ich kann hier bezahlen.
Den Apéro?
Nein, hier ist keine Kasse.
Kann ich das hier bezahlen?
- Ja, das machen wir jetzt so.
Was die gemacht haben:
Sie kamen aus der Schweiz.
Mit dem eigenen Geld machen sie
das Ding fertig, das Wahrzeichen.
Super. Das hält wieder 100 Jahre.
Was die Stadt Cuxhaven nicht
hingekriegt hat, machen die hier.
Haben Sie drinnen
auch schon aufgemacht?
Nein, nein. Wir testen mal draussen,
ob es überhaupt funktioniert.
Dann drücke ich Ihnen erst mal
für draussen die Daumen.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert.
Sie werden erwartet.
Die Schlange wird nicht kürzer.
Die Stunden verstreichen.
Vielen Dank.
Ja, genau.
Mal nur Gläser, das ist ganz gut.
Meine Freundin
wartet auf ihren Cappuccino.
Und in der Zeit mache ich mich
hier einfach nützlich.
Wenn jeder was tut,
dann klappt das ja auch.
Weil die Leute warten ja leider
Gottes 30 Min. auf ihren Kaffee.
Es läuft super.
Es ist unglaublich, was da abgeht.
Es entschädigt wieder.
Danke vielmals.
- Okay, meine Liebe.
Tschüss. Tschau. Danke.
Cuxhaven hat die Schweizer
Auswanderer ins Herz geschlossen.
Die Anteilnahme
überwältigt Mirabelle.
Es ist gewaltig. So schön.
In Gstaad macht sich Nicolas
Caboussat bereit für den Arbeitstag.
Nicolas macht den Hauptservice.
Auf der Terrasse und hier drin.
Nach der Ausbildung in Deutschland
arbeitet er in einem Viersternehotel
in der alten Heimat.
Ah, super.
Er fühlt sich in der Schweiz wohler
als in Deutschland.
Die Norddeutschen
sind halt sehr direkt.
Wir Schweizer sagen eher: "Man hätte
es so oder so machen können."
Die Norddeutschen sagen:
"Du hast es falsch gemacht."
V.a. im Norden.
Da sind wir anders drauf.
Das ist die Kultur, die ich mag.
Auf die rechte Seite, 106.
Ist alles gut bei euch?
- Wie weit ist euer Turm?
Jetzt ist er langsam fertig,
endlich.
Nach fünf Jahren ist es Zeit,
dass es endlich fertig wird.
Schön. Wir kommen mal schauen.
Auf jeden Fall. Sehr gern.
Wunderbar. Merci.
Trotz aller Rückschläge:
Nicolas hat volles Vertrauen,
dass der Turm bald eröffnet wird.
Ich bin zuversichtlich -
muss ich ja sein.
Wenn meine Eltern sagen,
sie machen es,
dann ziehen sie es 100 % durch
und dann ist es so.
Das war immer so.
Und es wird auch in Zukunft
so bleiben.
Auch Nicolas zieht seine Pläne durch:
Schon bald wird er die RS antreten.
So, hier wäre der Kaffee.
Die Mietwohnung in Cuxhaven:
vom vermeintlichen Provisorium
zur Dauerlösung.
Die Eltern haben ihr Büro im
früheren Kinderzimmer eingerichtet.
Wir vermissen die Jungs.
Aber andererseits gibt es uns
trotzdem auch etwas Luft.
Ich musste sonst immer schauen wegen
des Kochens, wann sie heimkommen.
Jetzt kann ich mich noch etwas mehr
auf das Ganze konzentrieren,
was den Wasserturm betrifft.
Caboussats sind Eigentümer
und Bauleitung in einem.
Hast du noch irgendwelche
Preisvergünstigungen?
Ja, wart schnell.
LED-Rabattcode. 5 Euro.
Hast du?
- Ja, super. 5 Euro.
Ja, das ist aber gut. Immerhin das.
Den hab ich noch für dich.
Nach dem Abenteuer
mit der Ausseneröffnung
richtet sich der Fokus
wieder auf den Innenausbau.
Hast du gesehen, die Wand?
Jetzt glänzt sie halt noch etwas.
Die wird noch geölt.
Und die hier wurde heute gemacht.
Das muss noch einziehen.
Und wenn das Gestell davorsteht,
sieht man diese Sachen
auch nicht mehr.
So, fertig.
Und das hier auch nicht mehr.
Das ist einfach so.
Wir sind hier im Café.
Es ist ein kleines Café
mit 20-24 Plätzen.
Aber siehst du:
Die Decke kommt schön.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Sehr gut.
- Super.
Das ist eine schöne Farbe.
Ich habe Freude.
Du hast recht.
Mir gefällt, dass etwas passiert,
ohne dass ich dauernd
danebenstehen muss.
Jetzt sehen wir endlich
den Horizont.
Hierhin kommt die Abwaschmaschine.
Hierhin kommt das Geschirr,
dann kann man es spülen
oder in die Abwaschmaschine stellen.
Nachher kommt es hier sauber raus.
Ich hoffe, ich werde nicht
hier drin gefangen sein.
Dass ich auch noch rauskomme.
Ich mache es sehr gerne,
backen und alles.
Aber jetzt, da wir am Wochenende auf
der Aussenterrasse geöffnet haben -
es ist auch schön,
Kontakt mit den Leuten zu haben.
Das ist mir wichtig.
Es sieht danach aus, als wären
Caboussats auf der Zielgeraden.
* Klingeln *
(Lautsprecher) Dritte Etage.
Das kommt dann hierhin.
Hier sollen bald
die ersten Feriengäste einziehen.
Oh, hier ist Wasser.
Das ist nicht gut.
Ich muss schnell ein Foto machen.
Ich muss die überprüfen. Jetzt
muss ich bei jedem Fenster durch.
Wir hatten grosse Probleme.
Ich muss schauen, ob die andern
dasselbe Problem haben.
Das würde mich sehr belasten,
wieder einmal.
Das ist immer ein Riesenhighlight,
wenn alles trocken ist.
Am Anfang hatten wir
acht bis neun Fenster,
die nicht dicht waren.
Und zwar immer auf andere Art.
Das war so schlimm.
Und jedes Mal war das Problem,
dass das Wasser hier runterlief
und die Wände nass waren.
So konnten sie nicht streichen.
So, das ist alles gut bis jetzt.
Uh, aber das ist nicht gut.
Das ist nicht gut.
Scheisse.
Hier ist nass.
Das darf ich Mirabelle nicht sagen.
Es ist besser,
wenn ich nicht immer alles sage.
Guten Tag, Herr Köster,
hier ist Caboussat vom Wasserturm.
Ich sehe Wasser -
wieder beim Fenster.
Wenn Sie dann kommen,
wäre ich froh, wenn Sie überprüfen,
ob das wieder ein grösseres Problem
bei diesem Fenster ist.
Jetzt gehen wir jedes kontrollieren.
Das ist am einfachsten.
Wind und Wetter zerren am Turm.
Runde Wände ...
... hohe Räume.
Hier gibt es keine Standardlösungen.
* Piepsen *
Die Eröffnung im Sommer
war ein Wunschtraum.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Du musst noch aufs WC sitzen.
Du musst sagen, wo du
die WC-Bürste und das Zeug willst.
Aber jetzt sind
die drei Ferienwohnungen fertig.
Wie hoch kommt es?
- Wie du willst.
Hier 70 cm.
Oder zumindest fast fertig.
Und wenn es nicht 70 cm sind,
ist es Pech.
Aber es ist genau so.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt können wir uns
um Details kümmern,
die vor einem Monat
noch in weiter Ferne waren.
Es gab einen rechten Sprung
vorwärts.
Das waren Details,
bei denen man gewartet hat,
darauf hinzuarbeiten.
Wir würden gerne hier wohnen.
- Aber wir vermögen es nicht.
Jetzt müssen wir halt verzichten.
Das ist schon okay.
Für 250 Fr. pro Nacht sollen
die Ferienwohnungen vermietet werden.
Ganz ausgestanden
ist der Ausbau noch nicht.
Die Fenster sind immer noch
nicht dicht - über zwei Jahre.
Jetzt kommen sie nächste Woche
noch mal, um sie zu machen.
Sie kamen sicher schon
sechs- oder siebenmal.
Ich habe die Vorhänge rausgenommen.
Der Strom von Aufgaben
will nicht abreissen.
Der Winkel ist so ...
Voilà.
Jetzt kannst du abschalten.
Dann sollte es hier abschalten.
Ja, genau.
Den Boden muss ich noch machen.
Den muss ich hier polieren.
Eigentlich mögen wir
gar nicht mehr so.
Das ist so.
Wir freuen uns extrem fürs Café,
wir freuen uns,
dass wir das alles geschafft haben,
aber die Batterien
sind schon langsam durch.
Es war ein Kampf,
ein kompletter Kampf.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass man so dranbleiben muss,
damit es überhaupt so weit kommt.
Was willst du noch alles?
Ich kann sonst heute Abend
noch fertig machen.
Ich muss zuerst unten, unbedingt.
Unbedingt.
Ausruhen können sie noch nicht.
Heute gibt es
den ersten Anlass im Wasserturm-Café:
Als Dankeschön
haben Mirabelle und Alain
rund 30 Freundinnen und Freunde
eingeladen.
Alles hat etwas gelitten.
Es hat wirklich sehr gelitten.
* Hupen *
Hey!
Komm rein, komm rein, komm rein!
- Schön, Nicolas!
Sohn Nicolas ist eigens aus
der Unteroffiziersschule angereist.
Ich muss zuerst noch duschen.
Ich habe nur Trainerhosen an.
Bist du extra zum Helfen gekommen?
- Selbstverständlich.
Er hatte gestern Abtreten
und fuhr die ganze Nacht
und kam hierher.
- Und wir wussten es nicht.
Wir wussten es nicht.
Ja, ja.
Du bist immer für
eine Überraschung gut. Hei, ei, ei.
Hallo, Beni.
Ihr seid die Ersten.
Hereinspaziert.
Hi!
- Lass dich drücken! Alles Gute!
Hallo! Hallo, Carla. Hallo.
Geht einfach rein!
Soll ich Stühle holen?
- Ja, gerne.
Die Kissen -
wo hast du die hingetan?
Obendrauf.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Alles Gute zur Eröffnung.
Danke.
Ich habe noch einen Zitronencake,
den ich auftischen muss.
Du, was mache ich eigentlich
mit den Leuten?
Soll ich mit ihnen raufgehen?
Oder wie sollen wir es machen?
Ich sagte, um 13.30 Uhr,
wenn alle da sind.
Dann sollten sie etwas trinken.
Eigentlich muss man sie empfangen
und etwas zu trinken anbieten.
Soll ich das machen?
- Ja, mach das.
Was darf ich anbieten?
Wir haben alles Mögliche.
Ist das ein Flat White?
Nimmt Sonja den Flat White?
Nein, sie nimmt nichts.
Sie will Wasser.
Nicht stürmen.
Hallo!
- Vielen, vielen, vielen Dank.
- Alles gut?
Danke schön. Ja.
Oh!
Der Cappuccino.
- Danke.
Sehr gerne.
Erst mal ganz herzlichen und lieben
Dank, dass ihr alle gekommen seid.
Es freut uns unglaublich.
Ich bin im Moment in einem
Wechselbad von tausend Gefühlen,
die durch meinen Körper strömen.
Grosse Freude, aber auch müde.
Durch all diese Zeiten.
Aber der wichtigste Mensch
an meiner Seite ist Alain.
Er hat mich aufgebaut,
wenn es mir nicht gut ging,
wenn ich mal wieder mehr schwarz
als eine andere Farbe gesehen habe.
Was er hier geleistet hat,
ist fast unmenschlich.
Und ...
... dafür danke ich dir
von ganzem Herzen.
Ja.
* Applaus *
Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass Mirabelle Steuerexpertin,
Mehrwertsteuerexpertin, Anwältin
und alles Mögliche wird,
nur, um das vorwärtszutreiben.
Wir haben uns sehr gut ergänzt.
Wir wollten euch einladen,
weil wir gesagt haben:
"Ihr seid uns sehr wichtig."
Auch in dieser Zeit
habt ihr uns immer wieder besucht
und uns unterstützt.
Das ist sehr toll.
Das freut uns ausserordentlich.
Wir gehen eine Ferienwohnung
anschauen, wie es aussehen könnte.
Einfach mitkommen, sechs Personen,
die gerade Lust und Laune haben.
Geht mal rein.
Der Boden klebt noch etwas,
weil ich gerade eingewachst habe.
(Mann) Hier ziehe ich ein.
- (Frau) Ich auch!
Guck mal.
Fast 20 Jahre
war der Wasserturm geschlossen.
Die Einheimischen
sehen das Wahrzeichen der Stadt
zum ersten Mal von innen.
Das war schon eine Wohnung,
aber die war ganz anders.
Da war kein Durchgang.
Wir haben alles geöffnet.
Alles war zu. Kleine Räume.
Z.T. nahmen wir Wände raus.
Ich liebe die Heizkörper.
- Die liessen wir extra herstellen.
In der Schweiz. Die sind gerundet.
Ich darf gar nicht sagen,
was das kostet, das Ding.
So.
- (Frau) Oh!
Das ist das Emmental,
wo Mirabelle und ich
lange gewohnt haben.
(Kind) Könnte man auch fernsehen?
- Das haben wir nicht eingerichtet.
* Lachen *
Viele sagen:
"Das ist eure Lebensaufgabe."
Oder: "Das ist ein Fass ohne Boden."
Mag sein, aber im Endeffekt
ist es ein Projekt.
Es hat einen Anfang und ein Ende.
Aber mit Mirabelle würde ich
gern noch etwas Kleines machen.
Nur noch wir zwei.
Dann machen wir es so, wie wir ...
Ohne Brandschutz und Denkmalpflege.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.-Danke schön.
Pass auf auf den Stufen.
- Achtung, glatt.
Tschüss!
- Danke vielmals!
Bist du zufrieden?
- Ja.
Wenn man alles im Voraus wüsste.
Wenn wir jetzt das,
was wir an Erfahrungen haben ...
Die sind unbezahlbar.
Das ist sehr, sehr, sehr toll.
Wir würden es nicht mehr machen.
- Wir würden es nicht mehr machen.
Wenn wir das gewusst hätten.
In Deutschland sicher nicht.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Merci, Nicolas.
- Ja, merci.
Hallo!
- Salü, hoi!
Bist du erstaunt,
dass Nicolas da ist?
Du hättest auch kommen können.
Ja, das wäre eine Option gewesen,
aber ich muss arbeiten.
Das Haus war voll.
Die Leute hatten Freude, wir
hatten Freude, es war sehr schön.
Jetzt räumen wir auf, putzen und ...
... dann muss Mama schnell ins Bett.
- ... schnell ins Bett, ja.
* Ruhige Klaviermusik *
Merci.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2024